wie lange bist du wieder händlern
gewesen
ich lange es ist einfach passiert der
neue and men film heißt and men the wars
also ist es eigentlich nicht nur and men
2 sondern es gibt auch direkt noch eine
zweite helden nämlich die wespe wars und
das ist in gewisser weise so was wie das
missing link der bislang marvel
kinogeschichte den büros bis eine ganz
klassische comic figur aus den 60er
jahren die mit zu den gründern der
avengers damals in den comics gehörte
eine ziemlich alberne figur nämlich eine
frau die sich klein machen kann wie eine
wespe genauso wie auch and men als der
ameisen man jemand war das ein super
kraft vor allem darin besteht dass er
sich winzig klein machen kann
aber dann mit ameisen kräften unfassbare
dinge bewegen kann dass man auf die
beiden figuren bei marvel lange
verzichtet hatte für die kinogeschichte
ist nicht so ganz überraschend denn das
war vor allem wirklich albern auch schon
in den comics der 60er jahre
und irgendwann hat man gemerkt hey wir
können nicht immer nur diese unglaublich
pathetischen superhelden geschichten
erzählen wir brauchen noch so etwas wie
komödien im superhelden genre
dafür hat man and men wiederbelebt oder
überhaupt das erste mal ins kino
gebracht und nachdem das ein ziemlicher
erfolg war kommt jetzt eben auch dazu
und da die beiden als naja sagen wir mal
insekten verwandte sich natürlich
perfekt ergänzen hat man jetzt den
gemeinsamen film gemacht und das ist
eben wieder eine superhelden komödie
[Musik]
das ist genau der gedanke den marvel
zurzeit verfolgt wir brauchen mehr
heldinnen
da ist natürlich der erfolg von wonder
woman wahnsinnig wichtig gewesen aber
das war bei der konkurrenz von dc und da
hat man gesehen dass kammern eine
richtig begeisternde verfilmung von
superhelden zu machen die an den comic
selber keine so wichtigen rollen
jahrzehnte lang spielten captain marvel
wird dann als nächster großer marvel
kinofilm tatsächlich auch mit einer frau
in der hauptrolle besetzt sein das volk
nur dem was in den comics in den letzten
jahren auch schon passiert ist
die schule heute hat macht die sache wie
üblich gut der hat einfach eine
wunderbare mimik mit der er mit ganz
kleinen gesichtsbewegungen eine gewisse
irritation ausdrucken kann
das ist wieder mal sehr solide aber
jetzt auch nicht so besonders innovativ
er macht genau das was and men 1 auch
schon ausgezeichnet hat er dann doch
eine große freude ist es michael douglas
der ja auch in and men 1 schon denn ja
sagen wir nicht verrückten aber doch
etwas sonderbaren wissenschaftler
spielte der überhaupt dafür
verantwortlich ist dass and men in
dieser lage ist sich zum insekten
kleinen menschen zu verwandeln und
michael das spiel das ganze diesmal in
einer etwas ernster und form weil die
große backup geschichte die es diesmal
zu erzählen gilt die suche nach seiner
im quanten raum verschollenen frau
darstellt
[Musik]
die qualität dieses films ist jetzt
nicht das wo man sagen würde er damit
ist die zukünftige marvel produktion
gesichert
da müssen die sich schon noch ein
bisschen mehr mühe geben aber was
gelingt obwohl es fast den ganzen dauer
des films über nicht den anschein hat
ist es dann doch in die unmittelbare
zeit der letzten marvel filme mit
einzubauen
er knüpft unmittelbar in den dritten
avengers film an und hat dadurch auch
einen ziemlich fulminanten schlusspunkt
mit dem man irgendwo nach dem leid
hearted storytelling des gesamt films
gar nicht so gerechnet hätte dann doch
noch einen richtig überraschenden
schluss und etwas was dann auch wieder
neugierig macht auf die fortsetzungen so
gesehen macht marvel das extrem
geschickt aber ob das tatsächlich über
jahrzehnte hinweg gehen würde ich hoffe
es nicht nicht wage es zu bezweifeln
[Musik]
den film müssen sich alle leute
anschauen die bei marvel universum auf
dem laufenden bleiben wollen
denn natürlich gibt es auch da wieder
ein paar nette kleine hinweise die man
brauchen wird um die zukünftigen filme
zu verstehen und guten gewissens kann
man sich anschauen wenn man superhelden
gar nicht so ernst nimmt und dann kann
man auch notfalls fünf minuten früher
aus dem saal gehen dann wird es wirklich
dramatisch ist denn das etwas leichtere
ist dann eben zu ende dann wird es ein
bisschen gravierender und
dementsprechend wäre die komödie haben
möchte der ist mit den ersten 120
minuten blenden bedient und da der
abspann allein schon fast zehn minuten
dauert kann man sich eine viertelstunde
vorher aus dem kino
[Musik]
großartig